while a school Community is coming
together to help a local teacher in her
time of need Jessica vanzella was
recently diagnosed with cancer and needs
help paying for treatment eight news now
reporter Sasha Loftus joining us in
studio with how those closest to her
have made it their mission to help out
yes Brian and Denise those we spoke with
tonight say Jessica is not just one of
the best teachers they know but she's
also an all-around amazing person that's
why they want to do everything they can
to make this tough time just a little
bit easier
I really think that she is an amazing
teacher it's just really inspirational
seeing her like help everyone around her
family friends and former students
sharing what they love about Jessica van
Zella loving caring she really brings
science to life I'm very proud of her in
the past eight years Miss V has changed
countless lives while teaching at
Somerset Academy in North Las Vegas we
need everybody's help to make her life
easier so she doesn't have to worry
Jessica was recently diagnosed with
breast cancer so this group is coming
together and doing what they can to
support her treatment she's going to
have a lot of bills that are uncovered
and not paid for and you know with
school and being sick and everything
she's got a long road ahead of her a
main part of that raising 85 thousand
dollars to cover chemotherapy surgeries
and any other procedures so far they've
received about 10 percent of that
Jessica says she's Blown Away to see so
many behind her my heart is just
bursting with joy that like all all of
the community of school and the
community my family and friends just
literally the support that they've shown
is outrageous but those who have
witnessed her heart in action say it's
the least they can do for someone who
has given so much we all come from
teachers and that teachers are probably
why we're all doing all the things that
we are today
Jessica's loved ones have started to
GoFundMe they've raised just over eight
thousand dollars in four days her
students and fellow teachers are also
planning a community car wash at the
school to gather donations Denise